Toyota knows how to make cars does it so
well it became the first company to
produce more than ten million a year its
success is rooted in a special system
and began what's now known as lean
manufacturing and ethos emulated by
companies around the world to make
products faster cheaper and better
here's how Toyota changed the way we
make things following the Second World
War Japan was left in a precarious
economic position steel and other metals
are scarce already disadvantaged by
lacking natural resources materials were
hard to come by and companies had to be
creative to compete
Toyota's founder Sakichi Toyoda had
started a loom business but it was his
son cachero who founded the motor
company in 1937 they were used to
working within narrow margins as the
shortage of materials increased during
the war the number of headlamps on its
Model K truck was reduced to one and it
only had brakes on one of the axles the
turning point for Toyota's production
system would come in the early 50s when
Keith sharrows cousin AG would travel to
the US with a veteran loom machinist
taiichi ohno they visited Ford's River
Rouge plant in Michigan and were
impressed by the scale of the operation
but knew that in cash-strapped Japan
companies didn't have the resources for
such a system having months worth of
stock sitting in a warehouse would tie
up precious capital they didn't have
instead what truly impressed Ono was a
visit to a supermarket the Piggly Wiggly
according to legend Japan didn't really
have self-service stores at this point
and he was struck by the way customers
could choose exactly what they wanted
when they wanted he decided to model his
production line on a similar idea with
the supermarket formula only enough
parts were produced in the first phase
to replace what was used in the second
and so on this is where the just-in-time
system really took shape
Toyota was able to eliminate much of the
waste in forward system making smaller
numbers of parts to be used when it
needed them allowing the company to
operate on a tighter budget as part of
this Ohno developed Kanban a sign based
scheduling method which shows goods in
goods in production includes out it's
now seen as a precursor to barcodes Ohno
and Toyota also noticed that American
car companies were still employing many
of Henry Ford's early production
techniques they kept operations at Full
Tilt in order to maximize efficiencies
of scale but then had to repair
defective cars after they rolled off the
line
Ono believe this caused more problems
and didn't encourage workers or machines
to stop making the mistake so he placed
a cord above every station which any
worker could pull to stop the entire
assembly if they spotted a problem the
whole team would work on it to prevent
it from happening again as teams
identified more problems the number of
errors began to drop dramatically
combined with the culture of continuous
incremental improvement called Kaizen
the Toyota Production system built a
brand known for making reliable and
affordable cars but Toyota was also
getting good at producing cars quickly
in 1962 the company had produced 1
million vehicles by 1972 they'd produced
10 million it was around that time that
the efficiencies of their factories
enabled Toyota to produce a car every
1.6 man-hours much lower than their
competitors in the u.s. Sweden and
Germany and as the oil crises of the
decade st. gas prices higher cheap to
run Japanese cars became much more
appealing to Americans whose powerful
but gas guzzling vehicles suddenly
became very expensive to rock today
Toyota has made over 250 million
vehicles others have looked at them to
learn the lessons of lean combining
craft with mass production avoiding
waste while striving for constant
improvement Boeing is perhaps the most
famous restructuring a plant to better
suit TPS Intel is another longtime lean
ambassador and is exploring the
principles in the context of AI and the
Internet of Things a Canadian hospital
even used Toyotas system to decrease
wait times in its er the Toyota
Production system changed not just how
cars are made globally but how we
approach making things from stock it
also showed that there's always a better
way to make a product
you
you